jordan belfort oh my goodness this final
story has to do with the real wolf of
wall street love him or hate him this
guy puts himself out there i'm talking
about obviously jordan belford and
basically he had some strong advice for
a person your age 25 year old he says
yeah yeah your little job
where uh you make uh 60 grand a year and
you're working nine to five yeah you
need to quit that you're never gonna get
ahead in life this is his advice
he says this and i i've got some things
that i agree with this guy on i have
some things that i certainly disagree
with this guy on for sure so
uh let's just state some
quick facts
um he went from rags to riches to jail
you know in that order
for stock market minimalism he's
probably the most glorified scam artist
of all time you know people love him but
obviously the people that he ripped off
don't exactly got love for this guy okay
and if you look at his at his net worth
he is negative 100 million dollars
negative 100 so he went on a rant
recently uh basically just smashing and
debunking the traditional uh career path
methodology that's basically been
planted in our heads since
grade school okay school system he
basically says these traditional ways is
going to make you die
and retire with no money this is what he
says he says quit that job the 60k nine
to five job 25 quit that job get a
better job you got to think bigger
you're never going to get rich
and you're never gonna get ahead in life
if you
or you have financial security working
for someone else is what he says and you
gotta get a second income this is what
he says so
quit your job
and just do something better
you get
let me unpack there's so much to unpack
here okay like ridiculous
i do understand
when he wants to think big this is the
guy that basically said you show me your
pay stub right now for 75 000 i quit my
job i work for you yeah you see in the
movie okay i get it he thinks big but
he's also a man of excess he's amazing
not just a normal guy so normal people
can't take this guy's advice he's the
type of guy that wants to do something
crazy big with his life even if he ends
up in jail
okay right not exactly the best advice
for normal people but basically you know
who this job you know this uh advice is
for
sales sales sales sales sales sales
sales if you want to make more money you
have to be in sales of some capacity but
that's not for everybody
sales isn't for everybody because sales
is a lot of entrepreneurship you guys
know this if you're an entrepreneur
a lot of stress
a lot of crazy nights a lot a lot of
struggling your ass off for the first
few years it's not easy but some of
these sales guys over here are starting
to make some major money so i do
appreciate what he's saying like look
you can't just be normal if you want to
be big okay so i understand that
but
that's not for everybody now let me give
let me give this silver lining here let
me tell you where i disagree with the
wolf of wall street and i actually think
that he's dead wrong
if you're a traditional person you got a
traditional job you're making 50 60 70
grand a year yeah you can still get
ahead right clearly it's just not going
to be get rich quick stuff like the wolf
of wall street correct let me tell you
something
if you're actually following the stuff
that we talked about like the stuff we
talked about in the budgeting 50 30 20
budget spending a certain amount on
housing spending a certain amount of
food understanding that you know income
ratio boom bomb cash flow you know if
you're doing all that you're setting a
budget you're saving that money stacking
cash you're getting out of horrible debt
you're starting to invest if you work
for a decent company and they have a
401k with a match with benefits and
health insurance and you're doing things
the right way you can end up becoming a
millionaire for
sure if you do things that it's gonna
take time yeah it might take you to your
60 and 70 and you retire and you get a
couple million bucks what's sitting in
your 401k or your roth ira or your 403b
whatever it is it's going to take time
so a lot of his advice has to do with
getting rich quick
again
he's worth negative 100 million he's not
the type of person that says yeah good
luck with your 50k job and keep going to
work and do the lunch pill that's not
his methodology he's a man of extreme
excess and extreme ridiculous lifestyle
so
there's a difference the get-rich-quick
stuff or the long-term approach you can
get rich you can retire wealthy you can
become
chilling at a sixty thousand dollar
salary fifty it can happen now couple
that with the fact that
you're gonna get a raise every few years
your
your income can go up you can have a
side hustle and make more money
again there's certain things i agree
with and certain things that the wolf of
wall street just doesn't understand
about the working person he's never been
a working person yeah he's been a scam
artist he's made millions of dollars on
on wall street he's the wolf of wall
street he doesn't have sound advice for
everyday working people making 50 60 70
000 i'm sorry he just doesn't
if you're a big thinker do you want to
be a sales person you want to make make
like
me someone like me that does sales that
makes high income cool i hear i hear you
maybe someone like me should have quit
my 60 000 job when i was kid and i did
but that doesn't different strokes for
different folks
so
agree but also disagree with the wolf of
wall street yeah i love the optimistic
view and like they be bigger than but
like also
don't i would disagree with this 25
years old and you're happy with your 60k
year job and yes that's kind of like
your stepping stone to the maybe 120k
yes do we got to start something yeah
you got to start you don't have to be
jordan belfort like that's the other
thing like jordan belfort
i i have a lot of opinions on this but
yeah that's the i 100 agree with you no
problem it's like
is yes if you enjoyed that short clip
from the sauce cast click here to watch
another click here to watch the full
episode or just stay broken